how to get over your fears I got a great
question i came in on youtube one of my
loyal viewers who wrote in to say that
she's afraid she wants to start a
clothing store but she's afraid that it
won't work out that people will like her
designs that she won't be able to
support her son she's so afraid that she
doesn't do anything she's just paralyzed
by her fear and she wanted my advice on
what to do so first of all understand
that fear is normal it's okay to be
afraid I don't know why people don't
talk about this more you look at you
look up to entrepreneurs we've had
success and you say wow they're so bold
they took these big decisions but they
were afraid to like you have to be
Superman and and pretend like you have
no fear you will have fear just use fear
as a counselor and not a jailer use fear
something that you can listen to and
help guide you but not that it holds you
back so much you your paralyzing can't
do anything so fear is normal that's the
first thing but I want to give you three
tips to help you get over whatever fear
you're facing now and help you build
something great and build a good life
for yourself and your family and
business you can be proud of so step
number one remember why you're doing it
whenever I felt afraid of something
whenever I felt like I wanted to try
something but I was it was afraid of
doing it I was scared I remember why I'm
doing it and that can help give you the
courage to start so for me I'm helping
entrepreneurs right I want to help a
billion entrepreneurs if I have to do
something scary for the first time if I
have to make a video like this when I
first started it was really scary but I
keep in mind that my goal is to help
entrepreneurs this is how I'm going to
do it or I might think of a specific
entrepreneur when I was first getting
started again there was one entrepreneur
who I'd helped out a lot and I always
look at him you know so when I'm looking
into the camera and I was scared to get
on camera I always imagined his face
Sarah now and I'm talking to him and
trying to help him out not that's why I
do it or I might think about my son and
building a better life for him and
leaving a lasting legacy and saying you
know look what look at what Dad did
and be proud of that so remember why
you're doing it remember wine and making
an important reason you're why has to be
important enough to shake you out of
your fear and move you towards action so
think about your son if you're starting
this store and you're afraid you won't
have enough for him think about your son
and why you're starting this or why did
you pick a clothing store have a
powerful story that guides you okay
that's number one number two is commit
to somebody when you commit to other
people you're much more likely to follow
through this is across any any
behavioral pattern that you have is a
person so if you commit to somebody else
you're going to be at a meeting you're
going to be there if you commit to
somebody else you're going to be at a
gym you're much more likely to follow
through on that Jim plan then if you're
just going to go by yourself commit to
somebody else I remember the first
presentation I did the biggest
presentation I did after I sold my first
company was in Brunei and I got invited
by the royal family Brunei to come and
speak to their young entrepreneurs they
were running out of oil money and wanted
to encourage entrepreneurs to be the
next wave and they wanted me to come and
inspire them and they had like a
thousand people in the audience multiple
cameras that were being filming and
broadcasting across the country I done a
lot of speaking but it was all small
little workshops and stuff not a
thousand people a nationwide
broadcasting I was afraid I know it's
kind of secretly hoping that they would
call me up the day before and say it's
off it's cancelled you know you don't
have to do it be the side relief I was
kind of hoping that would happen but
because I committed to them because I
said I'm gonna go I had to go right so
commit to somebody else that helps get
you over the fear of whatever action it
is so whatever you're thinking of doing
tell somebody else you're going to do it
commit to them step number three baby
steps start small you may see this big
thing as big picture is being super
scary and you're unable to do it but if
you break it down into little chunks
little baby steps you see whatever that
next step is it's a lot easier it's more
manageable it's achievable you know if
it doesn't say okay I'm going to take
over our stadium and I'm going to do a
presentation that might
be really scary I've never done that
before and I was looking at that when I
was starting up I might say wow there's
no way I could ever do that that's crazy
that's way too big and that fear might
be so paralyzing I don't do anything but
what's a small step to get their start
in front of the camera doing a little
workshop doing a presentation doing a
keynote traveling for the first time i'm
doing a keynote right like you start
building these steps and that the first
time you do it it's scary but you could
do it again and you think well I was I
was just so scared of that it wasn't a
big deal you know get in front of the
camera from it was really scary when I
started now I get in front of the camera
and it's no big deal like what was I so
afraid of right doing a presentation I
was scared sweating heart beating knees
shaking the first time I do a
presentation now I can get up and it's
no sweat and what I was thinking why was
I so that this is not that big a deal
but we build things up in our heads we
make things seem more important than
they are and it prevents us from
building something great you know to
build a great company you are going to
have to step outside your comfort zone
and address these fears if you don't do
things because you're too afraid you're
going to stick in your average life you
have to be able to be willing to step
into the fear to step outside your
comfort zone and do things that you
normally wouldn't do to get to where you
want to go so don't be afraid you know
shake off the fear it's okay to be
afraid at the start but don't let that
fear hold you back from doing something
great believe for those are watching you
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below let me know you think leave a
comment tell me about how you overcame
your fears or what you're afraid of
right now leave it below and you have a
question put in the comments of a video
response and subscribe to the channel if
you want to see more videos like this
thank you so much and I'll see you soon
you